foreign
[Music]
on translating cellular therapies from
bench to bedside my name is Catherine
Cook and I will be your moderator today
I work at next one bioscience a company
which specializes in the science of cell
counting and is now part of perkinelma
now I'd like to hand over to Dr Anis
kamani senior strategy leader in life
science at perk and Alma to introduce
our speakers
thank you Catherine
good morning good afternoon and good
evening everyone we welcome you all
to work in Elmer next salon's webinar on
Cell Therapy
thank you very much for your time to
join us today
uh combating disorders such as cancer
over the years as you all know have led
to the development of multiple
therapeutic approaches
and cell therapy has been one of those
in promising strategies against cancer
to that end today we will hear from one
of the leading Pioneers in the field of
cell therapy Dr Khalid Shah of Harvard
Medical School who will talk about
Innovative approaches in developing
Cellular modalities in its clinical
translation Dr Khalid Shah is vice chair
of research in neurosurgery at Brigham
and Women's Hospital Harvard Medical
School and also the director of stem
cell and translational immunotherapy as
well as principal faculty at Harvard
stem cell Institute
Dr Shah and his group's translational
stem cell research has globally been
recognized and highlighted
including BBC and CNN
in the second part of this webinar Dr
Jean Shu founder and CTO of nexilom will
discuss the importance of standards and
reference materials
and its value in
ensuring compliance of cell samples cell
evaluation during cell therapy workflows
and Manufacturing processes
prior to founding nexilum Dr Chu worked
for the 3M Company in various roles and
was instrumental in
invention of the first blue-green
semiconductor laser she has been awarded
34 patents and has to her credit over 58
peer-reviewed Publications
having said that
without further Ado I hand the floor
over to Dr Shah thank you Anisa for your
kind introduction and I would like to
thank
um hurricane Elmer and and next salon
for
um for inviting me and and allowing me
to present our our work in in cell
therapies that we've done over last
decade or so we do sell therapies there
are lots of other people other
researchers a worldwide who are involved
in cellular therapies
there are some bottlenecks in how do we
progress cell therapies from bench to
bed side and I'll take you a little bit
back into the the the agitation and The
Innovation mode so if you look at the
the hundreds of social change
initiatives over multiple years
um the three distinct roles played by
those who participate in moments
um and the the three distinct roles are
that uh are of the agitator so unless
you are not happy with the status quo
um you cannot innovate so the innovators
come into play when they want a change
and and that happens in the social
change scenario as well where
um you use sort of are not
um you don't agree with what is
currently happening and you want to
bring a change
um and and the innovator
um is born
um and then it's crucial for these for
these agitators or the innovators to
fully comprehend and respect the models
of all stakeholders their lives the
Allies the detractors
um and the people who are sitting on the
fence and and usually
um the agitators or who don't agree with
the current status or the innovators so
both the roles of energy agitator and
innovator are played by the same person
and in many cases if Innovation
um doesn't
um you know Innovation doesn't go to the
next level it is the orchestration
problem that we have not been able to
orchestrate what was Innovative and and
these are the
um this is what the focus of the cell
based Therapies in in current scenarios
that we have so many exciting options
for cell-based therapy there are T cells
there are there are stem cells there are
cancer cells that you can use for their
vaccines that we can eat can are we
orchestrating this well
um and and and then impact basically
requires all three you need a change you
need agitation you need Innovation
um of course and then you need an an
orchestration and and we know that
Innovation with that orchestration is
more like ideas without impact so I'll
give you a few examples so if you look
at the major cell types we we know that
there are embryonic stem cells and there
are adult stem cells and we never
thought you know that something that is
fully differentiated like an adult stem
cell uh would sort of go back and form
the basic stem cell that comes from the
blast Exorcist like an embryonic stem
cell but there has been agitation that
was going on uh since 1976 and that
finally gave rise to an ipsc cell and uh
when Professor yamanaka won the Nobel
Prize for physiology
in 2012.
um this was going on since 1976 if you
look at the fusion of the adult somatic
cell and an embryonic stem cell and
Dolly the sheep came into existence and
the first human IBS is in 2007 so there
was the concept that you can
de-differentiate a cell and and make it
a basic stem cell so this is one concept
and if you look at the ipsc applications
now
um this is really wide you can use this
in disease modeling drug Discovery and
toxicity tests the the applications are
endless similarly if you look at the
crispr crispr was adapted from a
naturally occurring genome editing
system in bacteria and and again the
idea was can we edit the genes in cells
with much more ease and the history of
crispr you know goes back to 1987 to in
2013 we had the successful crispr cast
home genome editing and again the
applications are endless crispr is used
almost in every modern lab now and as
compared to the to zinc fingers and
Talons
um sgrnas that are used in crispr system
are easier and cheaper to design and
applications again you can you can
identify Gene functions you can repair
mutations you can do disease modeling so
these are again two concepts and before
I go into the cell based therapies where
you know people or researchers were not
accepting the status code they wanted a
change and it did come it might have
taken 15 20 25 years but it did come so
there was some kind of an agitation
somewhere that led to innovation
so now let's go to cell based targeted
therapies I put them in two different
buckets and we might have heard about
this the autologous and the and the
allogenic cells or the logos you take
from the patient and these are include
the T cells the NK cells the macrophages
and then the ipsc cells that you can
make neural stem cells and the blood
cells from this and you can modify them
xvivo and Infuse them back into the
patients from an allogenic perspective
um you take healthy individual cells
modify them and put them into a patient
though one of the major differences
between the two cell types is that
allergenic is easily accessible it can
be off the shelf whereas autologous the
advantage is that it's patients own so
there is no rejection there's less
rejection but for the ease of doing
therapies and having therapies readily
available allergenic is the way to move
forward now from our work we've used
both allogenic and autologous more
allergenic where we used engineered stem
cells from a healthy individual and and
modified them and tested them in our
Mouse models and then the ipsc derived
neural stem cells and now we're making
NK cells so we have published
extensively on ipsc derived neural stem
cells and then from the autologous side
we pioneered the use of engineered
cancer cells
and then we are also we have some
compelling data on the car D cells and
the combination of engineered stem cells
and and called D cells so our uh Focus
has been uh canceled most of the times
we focus on the primary and the
metastatic tumors in the brain and and
if you look at the two images the one on
the left is uh one of my first last
author papers I think it was came out in
2010 p and as paper where we looked at
the migration of stem cells to the
tumors in the brain the green are the
tumors red are the stem cells and then
almost eight nine years later uh we sort
of pioneered the the use of cancer cells
to treat their own types and and I think
what happened in those eight years was
that we envisioned that technology will
develop in parallel I mean we would not
have been able to do the studies with
engineered cancer cells if crispr hadn't
evolved if lentiviral vectors hadn't
become better and easier to use so
technology is evolving and as an
innovator you have to think that that
technology can be applicable to any idea
that you have
um and you have to count that in
um to orchestrate it better that's
another example but I'll go into the
details of both of these um sort of
bigger ideas that we had using stem
cells to to Target tumors and using
cancer cells itself to Target their own
tumors
so bigger right bigger Focus
um is that we take two more cells and
tumor Associated endothelial cells and
immune cells and we look at receptors
that are specifically expressed on these
tumor cells and the cells and the tumor
microenvironment and then we engineer
stem cells with with Therapeutics or
ligands or antagonists or Agnes that can
bind to these receptors on the surface
of tumor cells or immune cells or
endothelial cells so we have not only
made stem cells releasing proteins but
also oncolytic viruses which I'm not
going to go into the details in the
interest of time and immune modulators
again very less I'll talk a bit less
about that and some engineer teeth
called t cells but we have made a cancer
cell that I'll talk a little bit more
about so this is one of the examples
where we use stem cells to release a
ligand which is binding to The receptors
on the tumor cells which are in red and
what you will see over time is that you
won't see the ligand but you would see
the killing of the of the red cells over
time this is a 54 hour movie and you
will see that that what you're seeing is
that the green cells
um remain unaffected so the ligand is
being released from the green cells it's
binding to The receptors on the red
cells and killing the the red cells
these are the tumor cells now we've done
we've published extensively on this and
others
um worldwide have published on stem
cells releasing Therapeutics and killing
tumor cells the question is again the
orchestration part how do you actually
translate this into clinics and one of
the you know tumors that we have been
extensively looking at is is uh gbm's
glioblastomers in the brain
patients with highly malignant
clearblastomers 80 to 85 percent of the
patients get tumor resection this is the
first line therapy followed by chemo and
radiation
um and what you see here is a full form
a full-fledged tumor and and a resector
tumor the issue is that when people do
get glioblastomas Unfortunately they
need to be resected once they get
detected the operation has to be done
within the first week so we don't have
much time to prepare patients own cells
and treat them with their own cells so
we've done Phantom studies with with
patients who have had gbms and and took
their MRI image just pre and poster
section and all we wanted to do is to
look at this cavity what is the cavity
size because we know that drugs don't
Cross Blood brain very efficiently stem
cells don't Cross Blood brain barrier
efficiently so we wanted to go locally
so our interest was can we can we
actually treat these remaining tumor
cells in the in the cavity and we've
done again quite a bit of work and so we
did calculate cavity sizes and build the
mouse model of resection and that mimics
these patient derived models so what we
did is we took these stem cells and
encapsulated it encapsulated them in the
bio-compatible hyaluronic acid-base gels
and what you see is the green stem cells
again releasing the ligand that binds to
the to the tumor cells and also cells
migrating out of the gel and and sort of
reaching far away from where the actual
resection site is in the brain
um and then treating and killing all the
red cells
now this works very well in culture and
we've shown that in Vivo when you take
these green cells that are releasing the
ligand to kill the the red cells if you
don't if you don't encapsulate them in
the gel they don't survive long but if
you encapsulate them in the things by
compatible gels they survive long and if
they're releasing the ligand that's
binding to receptors on the tumor cells
you actually get 100 survival in mice
yeah so we also created bimodal stem
cells that are co-expressing a safety
kill switch hs3tk and Trail and shown
that we we really wanted to make it safe
if we want to if we would take this into
patients
um so so a stem cell that is releasing
the like and Trail now also has a kill
switch
hsvtk whose expression selectively
sensitizes cells to gamsyclovir and it
can also be used as a PET Imaging agent
so we can now kill the stem cells when
we want to kill them after they have
treated the tumor cells and we can image
this by Pet Imaging as well
now the other
sort of aspect that we included in this
study is can we detect because we know
that trail binds to death receptor four
and five
um and some cells are resistant to Trail
the reason one of the reasons is that
the receptors for death receptor four
and five are not on the cell surface so
we created a system with with
um and Dan Haber and mamatoner at MGH
where we could actually look at
circulating tumor cells in the blood of
patients having brain tumor and also the
mice that were implanted with these
patient-derived cells
um and and using this steam cocktail so
we could actually look at circulating
tumor cells but now we've taken this to
the next level which is now the paper is
accepted in nature come where we can
detect receptors on these circulating
tumor cells so uh not only in Minds
bearing and these and these
patient derived tumors but also in
patients if you take a patient who has
been who's been detected with GBM if you
take the blood of these patients we can
actually look at the circulator we can
isolate circulating tumor cells and we
can look at death receptor four and five
in the extremacells so the bigger idea
is that when so let's assume a patient
gets detected with GBM
um has to be operated within the first
week we'll have blood within the 24
hours of detection we isolate ctcs and
look at the receptors we'll have our
cells allergenic
MSC is banked
um we already have the GMP grade ones
and we can so between this time a week
let's say a week we can actually take
these stem cells toward them and have
them ready for the implantation at the
time of surgery so we'll encapsulate
them in the gel and we'll place them at
the time of the tumor surgery within the
cavity that has been created by the
surgery
we can take this so we we've spoken to
FDA about this um a couple of times we
are about to submit an IND
for this and hopefully we'll have a
clinical trial soon the question
arises what happens to the cells that
are resistant to Trail can we bring can
we sort of
um
sort of uh sensitize these cells to to
Trail mediated apoptosis
um and we we've done number of studies
where we've used timozolamide to up
regulate Trail receptors and sensitize
them to Trail we've used pi3 kinase
Inhibitors but we wanted to build a
molecule that has the sensitizer and the
killer in the same cell and so we looked
at egfr nanobodies these are the
smallest functional fragments of a
naturally occurring single chain
antibody and we cloned these in
collaboration with uh with Paul hanago
and at the University of Utrecht we made
stem cells releasing bivalent nanobodies
and show that they can down regulate
egfr they can down regulate phosphoid
akt
um and and when we fused the the trail
molecule to the c-terminus of the Spiral
and nanobody luckily for us we you know
the egfr and dr4d are five receptors are
in the close proximity that's what our
threat studies show and then when this
molecule binds to the to both The
receptors
um the dr-45 and egfr
um we see apoptosis happening in
semi-resistant trail cells and if you
knock out if you use a toximab that
blocks egfr then there is no apoptosis
you know that implies that both
nanobodies nanobody and Trail is
important and if you knock out the R4
rdr5
then you also don't see any apoptosis
we've done quite a bit of studies with
GBM models but we've also done
um
a lot of studies in brain metastases
models and and this is a breast to brain
metastasis model where you don't get
solid uh you know nodular tumor single
deposits when cells go from breast to
brain they have multiple deposits in the
brain
like you see here in the in the MRI and
and the cartoon as well
um so we we've we've sort of looked at
all these metastatic tumors the base
alike the her2 the luminal a luminal b
breast and Cancers and looked at egfr
and dr45 expression and we see that egfr
is highly expressed
mbr45 as well but when you look at the
um
the match pair between the primary tumor
as well as the breast metastatic tumor
in the brain you see huge upregulation
of egfr and also dr5 in these in these
cells in these tissues and we've taken
all these 10 15 lines and looked at
egfrd or 4dr5 and we see again upper
regulation of of egfr dr4 dr5 both at
the cell surface level by flow and by
western western blotting as well so this
is a paper published in science advances
last year we I don't want to go into the
details of all the indivo in Metro
experiments but in Vivo we show that if
you
if you resect some of these breast
tumors in the brain a metastatic breast
tumors which in way small cases happens
we can actually increase survival in in
mice and then if you you look at this
very hard model we built a number of
mouse models leptin meningeal metastasis
model where you inject cells
intratically and you see that the green
stem cells are tracking the red tumor
cells and and again increasing survival
we've taken this now to the next level
where we're looking at immunotherapies
with with stem cells releasing immune
modulators and and killing agents like
Trail and antibody Trail
I want to shift gears to two little
stories that we have one if you look at
the trends in global limit oncology
um cell therapies are really moving at a
very very rapid Pace
um and so uh we we sort of had to shift
gears because most of our studies was
done in immune competent or immune
compromised mice we had to build Mouse
models that were from Mouse tumors so if
you look at the gbms
gbms are one of the coldest
immunologically cold tumors the reason
is that they have highest number of
myelody suppressor cells and they have
low degree of T Cell infiltration among
all the different uh six types that were
identified from 33 cancer types and 10
000 tcga tumors and so we built models
where we've looked at
um you know the mouse tumors Mouse gbms
in insane genetic mice or immune
competent mice and we've identified
immune active and immune inactive tumors
immune suppressive tumors and if you
take the immune suppressive tumor and
resac the tumor you see huge
infiltration of T cells great reduction
of myelow derived suppressor cells that
are in the core of the tumor and again
infiltration of NK cells and the CD4 and
cbat cells so we again just an example
we are looking at immune modulators and
and self-killing agents in one of the
molecules that we looked at is
interferon beta that that induces
apoptosis as well as acts as an immune
modulator and putting our stem cells in
the resection cavity and what we show is
that there's huge difference in survival
in these immunecompetent models as well
and we're taking this to the next level
where we're now using
um immune checkpoint Inhibitors which
are scfv fragments of either pd1 or or
pbl1
and this is an ongoing work which should
come out later this year or or early
next year the last part where I want to
spend two three minutes is our cancer
cell killing cancer cell story which we
published a few years ago the idea was
that we knew that Kansas has loved to
home to their own tumor types and and
they love to go elsewhere but because
the vasculator is not leaky they don't
end up anywhere else early on they end
up mostly in their own tumors and we
thought why not to modify these cancer
cells because they were homing to their
own tumor types and use them to kill the
tumors their own tumors and one of the
advantages was that there's patient
specificity and there are also natural
sources of tumor Associated antigens and
the other Advantage was that they
proliferate well so the ease of Gene
editing and Gene engineer sharing and
and next we were expansion is much much
easier so long story short so what we
did is we took a therapy sensitive tumor
cell we knocked out its receptors for
example Trail sends it to tumor cells we
knocked out dr4 dr5 to make them therapy
resistant and then we engineered them to
express the ligand or Trail in this case
and a safety kill switch and then Trail
would kill the original therapy
sensitive tumor cells and we will
ultimately kill the therapy resistant
tumor cells by activating the kill
switch
um so here are some of the data where if
we if you knock out dr4
um you get 50 resistant cells if you
knock out both dr4 and dr5 in tumor
cells you get almost 100 resistant tumor
cells and we've done this not only in in
brain tumors but also breast cancers
prostate cancer and number of other
cancer types now if you take the green
um RR therapeutic cancer cells they're
releasing the Therapeutics and if you
look at a few green cells can kill a
number of red cells not only nodular
tumors but also in invasive tumors and
then the idea is can we kill these green
cells by activating the kill switch and
here we show this in the gel where gel
encapsulated therapeutic tumor cells are
actually killing the red original tumor
cells and we can activate the
um
the kill switch both in vitro and v in
Vivo and we can kill these green cells
ultimately and we've shown this again in
a number of models one of the models is
the brain tumor resection model where
you resect the tumor and implant the
therapeutic cancer cells now in the
bi-compatible gels and show killing not
only of the of the original tumor cells
but also the therapeutic cancer cells
when we activate the kill switch
uh we've taken this again to the next
level because this was all done in
immune compromised mice and and
unfortunately in immune immune competent
Mouse the tumors of the mouse tumor
cells are not sensitive to Trail so we
had to switch to an immune modulator
um so we actually have two immune
modulators that
um are we knocked out the receptors as I
showed before now we have two immune
modulators released from the therapy
resistant tumor cells and the kill
switch the idea is to modulate immune
response locally activate program cell
death and then also activate the the
kill switches that would induce
bystander effect and then you will have
tumor antigens exposed and you will get
immunological memory so not only killing
Optima cells but also immune modulation
that might um have some kind of a
vaccination effect and the data are
there and so hopefully again in a year
or so we should be able to
um reveal those data and and hopefully
by then it's
um it will be sent to publication as
well uh so these are sort of different
concepts again uh I want to end with the
theme of of
um of uh sort of innovation
um and then agitation Innovation and and
orchestration and here is the
orchestration part how do you actually
translate therapies from from bench to
bedside and again patient becomes the
key aspect of this
um the molecular profiling of the tumors
and the access to the tumor cells the
excess to GMP facilities ultimately
after you have designed therapies and
for for us I think clinically relevant
Mouse models are a big part of Orchestra
and if you don't have those
well-oiled sort of clinically relevant
models that you can test your therapies
on it's hard to actually translate
therapies into the clinic so I want to
leave with uh with the with the
acknowledgments that this work would not
have been possible without
my team that is pretty International we
take pride in having at least 10 12
nationalities in the lab at one given
time and also our collaborators within
Boston outside Boston
um and and our funding agencies thank
you so much
all right uh today
um I'd like to share with you and the
other element of what translation which
is be able to make the cells be able to
make the cells to the regulator's
requirement so we can safely treat
patients
we have heard the very exciting
scientific advancement in the southern
therapy as shared with us from our last
speaker all these excitement uh in it in
order for us to translate that into
clinics to serve patients we have to
overcome some challenges and a lot of
times these exciting new therapies
involve scientific and Manufacturing
Novelties those other things never been
done before
we also heard Dr Shah talking about lack
of pre-clinical testing models as well
as Regulators have a new expectations so
it's in the New Frontier
fundamentally speaking the challenge
stems from cell therapies are living
drugs they are that complex
heterogeneous and the dynamic
so for next alarm we have been focusing
on our effort on being the innovator and
use our expertise in the science of cell
counting we've been doing that for many
years and indicated by over 14 cell
counting systems used in thousands of
labs we serve single sample workflow as
well as a multi-sample high throughput
automated workflows
so what do we mean by standardized cell
counting measurements there are actually
very important for cell Gene therapies
according to FDA it is a
it is used as a part of the
characterization of safety efficacy
Purity potency identity and the quality
of cells
it is used both for product in the
process development
and as part of a quality control test
panels for Source materials
intermediates and the products
it is important to use the cell con and
availability as a part of
reproducibility between Lots as well as
the work on comparability after
manufacturing changes
thanks
so according to FDA cell counting is
crucial during all stages of cell based
product development before you can file
for IND which is a permit to start
running clinical trials a lot of
manufacturing quality related
information has to be submitted before
they give you approval
after that when you are doing r d phase
one phase two phase three until they
give you Market approval there's a lot
of work goes into analytical procedure
development
so here is the example of process
pre-clinical cell counting method need
to be selected developed optimized in
Phase One there is a method
qualification and start to set some
release criteria during phase two the IC
ultimate optimization happens and the
validation acceptance criteria are
considered parameters are
proposed during phase three validation
has to happen and before they can
approve any drug for marketing
so accuracy in a position are two key
parameters for cell counting method
selection by definition accuracy is a
closeness of agreement between a
measured quantity value and the true
quantity value of a measurement the
position comes with closeness of
agreement between measure the quantity
obtained by replication
Illustrated in these targets if we can
always get to the center of it and then
and with very tight tightly hitting the
target means we have accuracy in the
position
if we can hear the target but it's
together around it we have accuracy by
the little lasso position
if we are closely clustered outside the
target we are precise but we're not
accurate if we are scattered all over
the place that means we don't have
either
accuracy is ideally evaluated using a
reference method or reference material
which has a true value
and the reference material in that by
definition is a material sufficiently
homogeneous and the stable with a
reference value
so now we have a dilemma because
lifestyle are Dynamic and they they
cannot serve as a reference material
so this is the background where the FDA
is actively engaged with ISO standard
development so far there are two
published accounting standards part one
is General guidance on Cell counting
method part 2 is experimental design and
the statistical analysis to quantify
content method performance
I would recommend anybody work on CMC
for cell therapy and purchase the
standards and they gave very good
guidance
so in excellent other than participating
in the standard development in the last
five years we thought a lot about how to
practice it so today during the time
limitation I will not be able to go in
depth please contact us we have a lot of
in-depth material on how to do it here
I'm just going through a few key success
factors
we already described briefly research
used cell counting is different than
cell counting procedures submitted to
regulatory Agency for drug approval FDA
care about quality in cell counting for
cell engine therapy
the cell counting method selection needs
to fit for field for purpose not to one
size fit all
so this is a slider borrowed from the
doctor
um Gibson from nist she was talking
about when you do fit for purpose cell
content method selection you actually
think about you're trying to count
some kind of cells a a in a matrix of BB
which you support the cell with and
using a particular counting method CC
for PD as a purpose are you doing
release testing for dosage evaluation
then that's very very critical
measurement or it's in process control
feel for purposely has a lot of
worksheets in the process to go through
if you're again if you're interested
contact us
so the next key success factor involves
we need to understand ourselves samples
we identify best cell country methods
before we select the cell content system
even the cell counting system is going
to include the reagents consumables
counting devices and the software
so in this picture I show you by using
fluorescent nuclear standing we can
identify and the nuclear cells in a
phrases samples without license red
blood cells this green color are
nucleated life
leukocytes the the orange color
indicated ones then you're going to
notice there's a lot of other particles
and these are either red Brussels or
playlists if you're doing a bright field
a tripod blue measurement either using
manual counting or VISA you're going to
over count
um
the live cell for this sample
so this is another indicator uh image of
a tripod blue stand Mouse lymphocytes so
the so you can look at the live cells
are these shining spots but the blues
buds are very diffused some of them are
diffused and they're very large and I
will show you a video of tripod blue
damage in this dying bad or dying immune
cells so in this example we aged some
jackass cells
and then we prepared the cell into an
Imaging slide
the next step we put some try pan on the
inlet port
allow it to diffuse and interact with uh
jacket cells and the way film it in
action
so if you look at the zoomed area when
the tripod diffuse in
see what happens to this particular cell
it gets expanded by interacting with
tripod
this is a more magnified case you're
actually seeing the explosion of the
cells it's going to repeat
so what happens with this situation and
that this this solves the mystery of
sometimes we have unrealistically higher
viability when using trip and blue cell
counting method
so next one I'm going to switch to
telling you about the quality of cell
counting results are determined by the
entire cell counting process not just
the cell counter itself
we have seen too many people focus on
selecting the cell counter however how
do you collect sample from your original
vessels how do you mix and prepare them
and how do you do data analysis after
you have the cell images they all
contribute to the counting result and
contribute to the quality
so the next step is about designing
experiments to obtain multiple quality
parameters for cell counting method
evaluation and develop development ISO
cell counting uh standard part 2 has a
lot of details in in that and we have a
lot of worksheets and the protocols
related to it after you get the cell
counting data it is important to use the
uncertainty approach to experimentation
and the statistical method to understand
the result what kind of variability do
we expect and also to set acceptance
criteria this is another area
um statistical knowledge is important
since we talked about uh lack of
accuracy standards for Life cells it is
important to do orthogonal
experimentation to help us understand
which is selected the cell counting
method uh have are more accurate
so the the next one is the more of a
practical matter most of us have not
done a lot of cell counting
measurements on different kind of
samples and with different
experimentation except an excellent
scientist and a field application sign
and the engineers have done hundreds of
these measurements we have a bank of
data can share with users just let us
know what you need
so it is important to know even we think
cell counting is the most fundamental
and straightforward measurement it's
actually not so to do it with a high
quality and and reaching out to us will
share with you uh on the knowledge
so we continue to work on viability in
collaboration with nist and it is
another uh critical uh quality attribute
for cell therapy
so I can't uh emphasize enough let us
help we have done worksheets webinars
different tools to use for increased
cell counting quality
uh before I finish just want to mention
not only the systems I use the GMP
related environment it started from
basic research and all the way through
the process if you want to translate
Cell Therapy fast start identify good
measurement tools and uses throughout
the process save a lot of time and the
resource thank you
thanks Dr Shah and Dr Chu for your
presentations thank you very much we've
reached the end of our scheduled time
now so I would just like to uh thank the
audience for joining today's webinar
um and I'd also of course like to thank
our speakers for their presentations
today I'm sure everyone found it useful
and interesting thank you very much